continuing our coverage of the annual
meetings in arizona and a guy that i
have seen everywhere in the couple of
days that we have been here getting
deals done making business happen and in
demand now that one of his biggest
clients has decided to walk away from
the game he is longtime nfl agent drew
rosen how's drew welcome back how are
you good to be here guys doing well
hustling you're right you know for me uh
i'm here trying to chase down the teams
at the combine they're chasing you right
for you know the the guys that they want
to sign right out of the gate
here now you're chasing the general
manager and head coaches to talk to them
about drafting your things like you're
free agents you haven't been signed yet
we're in the second wave yeah and of
course the draft yeah but at the combine
there are no discussions about contracts
right i mean free agents that doesn't
happen that is
that is such a joke
that's got to be the biggest travesty of
all you know you made the point i mean
they should just eliminate the whole
tampering stuff and just let it go right
yeah well but the way i understand it
you negotiated a deal with the raiders
for trent brown in three minutes i mean
it's very impressive
that was easy
that didn't take long given given the
amount you know when he became the
highest-paid offensive lineman that was
kind of hard to
turn down yeah so that one happened
pretty fast right i mean yeah do you i
mean does does a relationship grow from
there with just the raiders specifically
when you go into a big you know week of
talk about antonio brown and then right
yeah yeah it does definitely spend a lot
of time with well i've known coach
gruden for for years right warren sapp's
one of our retired clients so
coach gruden's been working with our
guys for for decades but mike mayok this
was my first dealings with mike as a
general manager
uh but the raiders they're a lot of the
people behind the scenes like tom
delaney he runs through salary cap he's
been there
as long as i can remember so i've had a
long relationship with mark davis al
davis this is my 31st year
so a lot of the people in the building
have been there yeah for for a while
right before we get to gronk antonio
brown was the story of the offseason for
the first couple of months and i kept
comparing him drew to another one of
your former clients terrell owens in
2005 and i remember what t.o went
through and how hard it was for him to
get what he wanted what has changed in
14 years where a player
called a shot and made it happen and got
out of a situation you didn't want to be
in
uh you know antonio had nine great years
there guys and when we met with the
steelers um in west palm beach we met
with the owner mr rooney and we met with
kevin colbert omar khan the gm and
assistant gm we just decided after
hearing antonio out that
it was best for him to move on i think
the steelers bought into the notion
that it would be best for everybody if
he was traded it really wasn't a process
of us just
forcing them to do it we explained our
position
and you know not everybody agreed with
the approach but at the same time there
were a lot of discussions going on
behind the scenes that were very cordial
yeah antonio's meeting with them was
very positive he and mr rooney they
hugged and agreed that it would be time
to move on that it was nine great years
but a change of scenery would be best
you know his relationship with ben
obviously was not the best the
relationship with
coach tomlin unfortunately was not at an
all-time high right and it made sense
for both sides to get going
um and you know going all the way back
to terrell's it was a little more
one-sided right at that point well so so
i want to piggyback off that a little
bit now with the antonio brown thing
okay so now you know it's time to move
on from pittsburgh
this is where first of all i'm amazed by
you you're oh players love you i just i
want to tell the audience that because
i've been i played for the moor and sav
he loved you uh anybody i've ever been
to when you were playing well i didn't
know him that way he didn't pursue me so
maybe
he's like i'm not gonna make any money
without you get out of here
uh but how how much do you get involved
with like antonio brown we're sitting
here doing tv shows going man the stuff
he's doing on social media uh it might
be hurting his trade value or his
ability to get on with the how much do
you get into people's lives that way to
steer them in the right direction well i
shared with antonio my thoughts that
i thought
you know less is more with with the
media and and social media and things of
that nature
but i always supported him you know i
will i will give him my recommendation
and he's his own man i'm his agent but
you know he makes his own decisions and
he'll certainly consider
my counsel
but it's not like we had this uh game
plan
to do stuff on social media it wasn't uh
something we concocted it was really him
just speaking from the heart sure
a lot of this was very emotional for him
he wanted to play in that last game very
badly
he wasn't able to do that the team
decided not to
um he was hurt by
some of the comments that came out
within the organization about
his conduct that week and whether he
gave up on the team etc right so a lot
of this was was pure emotion from him
um so it wasn't a scheme yeah as much as
he was reacting
to a new set of circumstances right but
just let him sit back and do his thing
even though you've made a recommendation
on how you think you should handle it
you know again you support your clients
as much as you can you try and guide
them but it all worked out in the end
you know i mean he's very happy
hopefully the steelers are happy to move
on and put that behind them they got a
couple draft picks they've drafted
really well in the past uh you know i've
heard kevin colbert make you know a
statement when when people talk about
wow third and a fifth yeah right i want
to ask you that next
yeah you know but he made the comment
recently hey that fifth could turn out
to be the next antonio brown antonio was
you never know they've done a great job
at the draft do you now call him mr big
chest
i never caught him that
i've always called him maybe but you
know we we've had a great relationship i
spent a lot of time with him because he
lives in south florida so we're
neighbors and we we uh we got together
quite a bit and kind of talked through
this wasn't easy it was very painful for
him because he loved his time in
pittsburgh and it was a painful divorce
right for both sides
this wasn't something that we went into
the last game and said you're never
going to play for the steelers again
this just happened this wasn't a long
time coming right this was something
that really blew up at the end of the
season and led to the partying aways
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports